on prime crime i went downstairs
this place was covered do you know what
they were hitting him with
the desperate search for a husband and
father i think you know exactly who did
this
and i think you're scared and the
investigation that leads to an
unthinkable conclusion chris durant
calls dispatch and that turns out to be
an important
moment right there
[Music]
hey there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime prime
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile and memorable true
crime cases
what starts out as a terrifying home
invasion
turns into something else entirely
titus county number one what's your
emergency i have a home invasion my
niece is tied up
she's caught up she is tied up and
gagged
it's february 20th 2015 in titus county
texas
ginger kesterson is on the phone with
police explaining that
someone broke into the home of her niece
i am untying her
i can't get the noise what is the
victim's name
samantha wolford according to wolford
she managed to break free from her
restraints and call her mom
who then contacted kesterson to come to
the house
during the attack her five children were
all asleep
however as for her husband the father of
three of those kids
ernest ernie ibera jr he's nowhere
in sight he's saying that they hit her
husband in the face about five times
and drug him out police quickly arrive
on the scene
so walk me through what happened i don't
honestly know what happened
i was in bed at sleep and we heard a
noise
and the second i was able to open my
eyes somebody grabbed me
and jerked me out of the bed and slammed
me down on the ground and started tying
me up
didn't recognize anything about they had
black masks on
black shirts black pants every
inch of skin was covered
home invasions are rare among
average people because of the fact that
there's so much risk involved right
because when you come into a home
invasion you're coming in
with force with weapons you're holding
people at gunpoint
the situation can easily spiral out of
control it was a very harrowing tale and
very dramatic
then when they dragged me downstairs
because they had him downstairs and they
were separating us
i went downstairs and this place was
going to play
do you know what they were hitting him
with
at one point samantha says they bring
her downstairs
and have her stand in front of him while
they say
how can you not appreciate what you have
here you have this beautiful woman here
how can you not appreciate this how
could he treat her so badly
that they exposed her and they used her
to taunt him
while they continued to beating why
would someone attack this couple
and where exactly is ernie let's take a
step back
after meeting in a tattoo shop in 2008
samantha and ernie began dating
samantha already a mother of two ends up
having three more children with ernie
and the pair wed in 2014 yet things
between the two
weren't picture perfect i don't think
that
they had a very good relationship it
looked to me
like he was doing everything he could
to keep the family financially afloat
he was working two jobs she was not
working so what was she doing
i've always wanted to be an actress i
think it is so much fun
one of the most amazing forms of art
ever to be able to express yourself that
way
wolford spent her days posting numerous
videos on her own youtube channel
when you first saw the youtube videos
you know it was more
like you know personable and she was
trying to do how-to types of videos
hey guys i'm doing a makeup tutorial
today um it's my first one so don't be
too harsh
but as time went on you saw her videos
become
much more darker much more complaining
about her relationship
really putting her personal life on
front street
hey youtubers today a lot of shit pissed
me off so you guys get to listen to it
his dad's not having a whole lot to do
with this pregnancy
and that sucks i'm kind of screwed
as far as dating goes because i
date losers i think that samantha had
this perception
that other people really cared about her
life and she fed into that perception
i think this was a source of excitement
for her and she
wanted attention the problem is is that
this really developed
into this kind of tunnel vision for her
it was her
only focus and her family was really
left to the wayside
what do you think of me making youtube
videos
well i guess i don't mind it takes up a
lot of time
this desire for samantha to become a
youtube star or some kind of influencer
really started to impact the
relationship between her and ernie
and ernie felt a little bit forgotten
i'm not going to light a cigarette oh
yeah i forgot about them because you got
that fucking ipad in your hands
where where where at least you're paying
attention
but only because this fucking hilarious
ass episode
coming up samantha sits down with
authorities
and she realizes who may be behind this
attack
i feel like there's something he hasn't
been telling me
but i don't know what what's your good
friend
i think it's something to do with his
dad
[Music]
they would have to either be familiar
with the place
to be able to do all that and know where
they were asleep
[Music]
in february 2015 authorities in titus
county texas are confronted with a
strange situation a woman named samantha
wolford explains
that unknown masked intruders broke into
her home
attacked her and her husband ernie ibera
and then
kidnapped him while her kids were asleep
upstairs
it's what wilford remembers though about
the comments from the assailants
that provides a new clue did you hear
him say anything else besides what you
told us
he said that it was because of his dad
because it was then yeah
okay his dad knocked on someone and got
their man thrown behind bars and now
they were taking revenge and taking
someone from him
could ernie's father somehow be mixed up
in all of this
as wolford later tells detectives she
thinks
he just might be his dad has a problem
with getting involved in things that you
don't need to be getting involved with
as law enforcement work to check out
this lead they notice
that some things are off i'm not really
seeing a whole lot of blood though for
somebody that was pistol-whipped
no everybody's wearing all black
black shoes no identifying marks on them
there's also the matter of a bound
wolford calling her mom
my mother was the first never on my call
list i just used my face and so instead
of calling 911 for help you called your
mother
how did you press 9-1-1 with your face
well how did you dive your mother with
your face
i didn't dial my mother i just pushed
the first thing that was on there
it just happened to be my mom i think
you know exactly who did this
i think the story's made up about about
the uh with your daddy
he's daddy and and stuff like that i
think you know
i think you know exactly who did this
and i think you're scared
samantha sees herself as an actress but
i think that she exaggerates her own
abilities
and investigators really see right
through her
the only other thing okay
see i knew you know you know sam you
know i'm not here lying to you
you know i know the only other thing i
know i don't even know
i know okay
i've been up in the hospital with my
french pilot
okay she's got a guy there and i swear
to god i cannot go up there that i
said any of this because they
have a lot of friends around here my
life will be in a bottom texture
okay i have a problem talking to my
friends about
our problem and he gets talking about
how a man should treat a woman that way
and how
you don't do those things to a person
he's gonna deal with the situation
i didn't take him seriously okay you see
sam you know who did this
okay who is this guy his name's jordan
jonathan his facebook is rebel john
rebel
as time went on her story started to
change
because the reality is when you tell the
truth the truth doesn't change
and when the details start to switch up
that is definitely a cue for law
enforcement that
there's more happening here and that
they need to dive deeper
what did you say when he said he's going
to take care of that problem i just
laughed at him i thought he was joking
so now all of a sudden why are you
bringing him out because you know that
it was him
i just have this feeling like it was
up next we find out who this john rebel
is
and also what happened to ernie
they never told me why they just told me
that they're gonna fuck this dude
[Music]
the evidence we're found on the scene
it's just not matching
i don't think you i don't think you harm
this boy but i think you know who did
it's february 2015 and young mother and
youtuber
samantha wilford admits to texas police
she may know who's behind the abduction
of her husband
ernie ibera she explains that one day
she had complained of her marital
problems to her friend's boyfriend
who cryptically said he was going to
deal with the situation
a statement that at the time wolford
said she didn't take seriously
this man was identified as jonathan
sanford
now jonathan sanford had recently been
released from prison
for molesting his cousin starting in
junior high
he enjoyed you know shaking kids down
for lunch money
he's just that kind of guy and he's
really unapologetic
about anything he did illegal wrong
immoral
police quickly arrest sanford as well as
his brother-in-law
jose antonio ponce jonathan sanford and
jose ponce were arrested the following
morning
and they were arrested because of
information
that samantha finally disclosed to law
enforcement
she had previously described that there
were three of them
so i think law enforcement believed that
there was at least one more person
involved
police also apprehend octavius lamar
rhymes
who sanford enlisted for the attack on
ernie
octavius rhymes was from the nearby town
of
pittsburgh he had been in the military
he was using drugs
methamphetamine specifically he wasn't
doing anything
productive and that's kind of what put
him in this situation
pretty quickly after the sheriff's
department
detained and arrested jose ponce
and jonathan sanford those two
individuals
talked sanford decides to open up to
police
and explains how and why they attacked
ernie
samantha talking about
her relationship with me and jay and my
sister
and all that and me trying to talk to
her and help
her out and all that because she seems
like a good person to me
and she was explaining to me how he
treats the kids and all that
if i ever see it or if i happen to be
around or if i ever
see her with bruises
it's almost like his attitude was well
you caught me so
i'm just going to lay it out there for
you sanford recounts that after
kidnapping ibera
they took him to the woods and killed
him
so jonathan sanford led the sheriff to
where the body was
sanford ponce and ryan's had taken ernie
to a remote location
they walked ernie through the woods he
uh was just in his boxers
he's been beaten to the point where he's
he's just moving
he's not really uh i don't think
coherent anymore
jonathan sanford had told us that his
plan
was initially to shoot ernie and then he
decided not to that he would slit his
throat
and then before he had a chance to do
that ponce shot him
definitely did okay
what we need to do now oh yeah he's dead
he's not going to be alive
john sanford said that he was he wasn't
expecting ponce
to do that he lifted up ernie saw that
he was dead
and said something to the effect of game
over and then they left
ernie ibera is found dead and the
killers are apprehended
you might think the case is closed not
quite
we're going to be you know checking your
phone records for the last few months
anybody that's involved in this and not
connected to your phone
no okay you're sure about that yeah
when we return
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
welcome to prime crime tonight another
day of drama between both sides from
multiple live trials daily to original
and compelling programming
the law and crime network is everywhere
and we invite
you inside the jury box this
is law and crime
i think all court shows are the same
we're talking about your father
guilty or not guilty guilty think again
judge caprio rules with common sense i
was having contractions i was rushing to
the hospital inspector quinn what does
justice demand
jail and compassion i'm going to take
the
circumstances into consideration the
best court experience i've had
clearly judge he's been in a court
before get caught
in providence
[Music]
let me on the face i need to know the
truth did you have anything to do
with
no in 2015 texas investigators make a
chilling discovery in the woods
the dead body of ernie ibera a young man
who was kidnapped after a reported home
invasion
police arrest three suspects jonathan
sanford
octavius rhymes and jose ponce
sanford would eventually confess and
direct police to the corpse
ibera's wife samantha wolford an
aspiring youtube star and mother of five
says despite her marital issues with
ibera she was not involved
she does admit though that she had
complained about iberra to sanford
who by all accounts got angry with how
ibera treated her
and their kids yet is that the whole
story
not even close we've got a pretty
volatile pass and we've arrested him
before yeah
authorities note that the scene of the
home invasion is suspicious
with no items taken the kids being
asleep the entire time
and the fact that immediately after
undoing her binds
samantha called her mom first not 911.
i think that samantha wanted extra eyes
i think she wanted people to be able to
corroborate her story
up to that moment it could have happened
like she said
the officers arriving on the scene did
not have any thorough understanding of
how fragile the ribbons that she was
tied up with
were and it didn't have the information
regarding how she got her phone and how
she was making phone calls
where did he take that well we've got a
search for your phone that phone's gonna
be ours for a while
things are just not piecing together
with your story
it's the phone data that would reveal so
much
let's go back to the body cam footage
from the night of the home invasion
they took his phone so he's got his
phone
no they have his that's what i'm talking
about hey
all right this is what we need to do i
need to do an emergency uh
phone pain and i've got the cell phone
number
chris durant calls uh dispatch
and when he's doing that she does ask if
she can
call or text her mother
yeah verizon gave us text messages
from octavius rhymes phone that showed
some back and forth between samantha's
phone and octavius's phone
we had messages from her to the
co-defendants
to try to help them evade law
enforcement so the first one was at 2 30
am comparing the time stamp on durant's
body worn camera
and her asking if she can call her mom
or message her mom at that moment she
sent
octavius rhyme a text that said to the
general effect
kill day's phone shut that down
day is a nickname that uh ernie alvarez
went by
they're trying to right now so it's so
fun
uh they haven't heard back yet then
there was a second message
she hears through the radio something
about an address in pittsburgh
from a residence in pittsburgh
you know anybody contact pittsburgh as
he turns around she's picking up her
phone
at that moment she sent another text to
octavius rhymes that said
ditch phone move and the phone records
then showed a 30-second call
between her and octavius rhymes
just immediately after that text
messages
very clearly showed that she was the
mastermind
that she was planning this this wasn't
an accident
she was an equal partner in all of this
not the innocent victim that she claimed
to be
she may have been frustrated with her
life you know obviously
24 year old mother five children money
is a con was a constant struggle
you know her husband was working several
part-time jobs
i've had a lot of people stop me and ask
about how i deal with things
honestly it's hard samantha had this
warped way of thinking this warped
mental state
that this was going to be the way that
she got out of her relationship with
ernie
the thing is if her plan was successful
and she didn't get caught then certainly
she would be the youtube star that she's
always wanted to be
this would get her a lot of attention
and she could play victim
and i think that's what she wanted
sanford and ponce pleaded guilty to
abducting and murdering ernie ibera
and each were sentenced to 50 years in
prison
rhymes went to trial in two different
counties but was convicted
in both cases ultimately receiving a
combined prison sentence
of 98 years as for wolford
she also had two trials we tried the
kidnapping first
what she was trying to do is distance
herself from the
text messages the position she took the
testimony that she gave
was that she had been prescribed ambien
for sleep problems
and that she had taken an ambien and she
really didn't remember anything that
happened
and didn't remember sending any text
messages the jury
i just didn't believe it and they
convicted
her of the aggravated kidnapping and
sentenced her to
50 years a few months later we tried her
on the murder case in camp county
and that jury gave her 99 years
when the jury sees you know the still
shots from the body cam with the saint
with her on her phone at the very same
time that the phone records show her
sending text messages to the people who
you know who killed her husband that's
some solid evidence that a jury
appreciates while wolford appealed her
cases
her attempts were unsuccessful and it
seems
she'll spend the rest of her life behind
bars
i can shoot somebody quick if they mess
with me otherwise i'm really nice
i love people i like along with people
so well
and they love me but
don't cross babies then i can be really
really mean
it's bad you know sometimes you just
can't make this stuff
up even as much as you want to for
samantha wolford she was looking for all
the fame and attention in the world
and she definitely got her moment in the
spotlight just not how she imagined
or wanted that's all we have for you
here on prime crime
leave us your comments on instagram and
twitter with the hashtag primecrime
as always thank you for joining us and
until next time
be safe
[Music]
you